heyhe a movie where we want a leans to
stay in the country and it's not machete
paul sao paulo's the story of the two
guys from Shaun of the Dead Simon Pegg
and the other guy whose name I always
forget who are a couple of hardcore
nerds sightseeing in America seeing the
things that everyone comes for UFO sites
and in doing that they run across Paul
in alien yeah like outer space and
and Paul like et just wants to go home
Paul's like a tease really dick brother
but of course they have a government
agent a man in black played by Jason
Bateman on their trail
so yeah this story has the two guys from
Hot Fuzz a few people from Judd Apatow
movies and a couple people from Arrested
Development so the movies like a crock
pot of win and awesome with an alien and
was it funny yeah it was pretty funny
mostly for me because of all the nerdy
sci-fi jokes in the movie
and if you've watched my reviews
carefully you'll be able to pick them
all out I've given you the tools to get
all the jokes in Paul kinda and Paul is
not your average alien he's voiced by
Seth Rogen so it's pretty much like Mac
and me with attitude but you guys never
saw Mac and me yeah me neither
would be weird now everyone in the movie
played their roles perfectly like Simon
Pegg and his friend what's-his-name they
were great Jason Bateman is the hardcore
agent on their trail and every weird
hick that they run into along the way
because when you're dealing with a movie
about aliens in America
Hicks men lots of crying Damon and I
will say this the movie was a bit
preachy not for Christianity you're like
against Christianity at a point it's
just getting crammed down your throat it
just felt like the writer had an agenda
and anyone can agree whatever your
opinion is if you cram it down people's
throats no one likes it it feels like an
action movie when someone like unloads a
gun on someone and the clips empty and
they keep pulling the trigger you know
like
kind of like that with jokes with an
agenda use sparingly don't compromise
the comedy never the comedy other than
that the movies hilarious and even throw
out references like he's affected pop
culture whenever you can take a movie
like this and reference pop culture like
the main character in this movie had
something to do with something that's
happened within the last 30 years I'm a
sucker for that I love it it's
awesome so if you like alien movies you
like rated our comedies you like aliens
that have rated our comedy humor and you
like sci-fi entertainment you want to
make a game about finding all the
references in one movie this is it I
would say the movies a good time no
alcohol required but if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more